[MUSIC PLAYING]
PATRICIA WALSH: So what we're
here today to talk to you about
is how we're working to
transform Dow Jones into a data
business.
So the data engineering team,
which Dylan was manager of,
we had the opportunity
to move an over
30-year archive of premium
news data to the cloud.
And by experimentation
with cloud-based services,
we were able to
identify usage patterns
and optimize our
architecture in order
to meet those usage patterns.
So what we're going
to talk to you today--
is how we were able to learn
through experimentation,
how we were able to
identify opportunities
to either optimize for cost
or optimize for customer
performance, and how
those lessons learned
have influenced how we're
transforming our business
and future-proofing in future
data-driven developments.
Go on to the next.
Dow Jones had an over
30-year of premium news data
that existed only in
on-premise infrastructure.
What we discovered
is that it met
the need of our existing use
cases, which are predominantly
around advanced
research and advanced
analytics, predominately
focused at research librarians.
But we were getting
increasingly frequent requests
for extractions of data.
And that was actually
really challenging in
our on-premise infrastructure.
So what the data engineering
team was charged with doing
was actually doing the
migration to the cloud
to support existing use cases
for the advanced research,
new use cases for machine
learning and big data
workflows, as well as
being innovative enough
to be future-proofing
for whatever is next.
So Dylan, what were some
of the original challenges
in making this data
available to customers?
DYLAN ROY: So for this
new class of customers,
these data scientists,
they required more data.
So we were trying to
fulfill their requests,
but they needed more data than
we needed for the researchers.
So with this on-prem
database, we'd
have to give them
the data on weekends
or over the low-traffic
times that we
had for our research product.
But that just wasn't working.
We weren't able to fulfill
the requests of our customers
that were needing this data.
As a result, we were
actually posed a question.
Are we going to stay
on-prem and try to scale up?
Or are we going to
move to the cloud
where we can massively
scale up ephemerally
like with ephemeral clouds?
So due to this lack of
bandwidth and this lack of scale
and the size of our team, we
decided to move to the cloud,
specifically, the Google Cloud
because they gave us zero-ops
options--
I have some listed here--
like Dataflow,
Dataproc, and also GCS.
I'll go over those when we go
over the architecture later.
So yeah.
I'm just going to hit home
again what the pros and cons are
for moving to the cloud.
You can scale massively,
especially for these data
science workloads
where you're going
to need large clusters
to process all this data.
For us, it's over
30 years of news
content from over
33,000 news sources.
It also allows for
smaller teams because you
have these managed services
that you can take advantage of.
It also allows to give you
disaster recovery capabilities
that previously
were not available.
Because, on-prem, we only had
a limited number of locations.
With GCP or with cloud offerings
that we have available to us
now, we can be located
in different countries
throughout the world.
And given this
upfront cost, we still
wanted to move
forward to the cloud.
So I'll bring it
over to Patricia
to continue us on our
journey after I step us
through the architecture here.
So here is our
simplified architecture.
What we had was a news content
feed on the right side there.
It's kind of shown
as a Mario work pipe.
And that fed into
GCS for storage.
And everyday, we'd have
a Dataflow job that would
process all those news events.
They were updates, deletes,
or additions of articles.
And that would be pushed
into to Datastore.
From there, our customers
interact via an API.
But this API, we had
to apply custom DSLs.
So that was problematic
along with the fact
that it was pretty
expensive off the cuff here.
And I'll let Patricia
let us continue on.
PATRICIA WALSH: So once
the 30-year archive
was moved to the cloud,
what we wanted to enable
was really the opportunity to
integrate our data with machine
learning workflows as
well as big data workflow.
So we identified two
delivery mechanisms
that we wanted to enable
via cloud services.
First delivery mechanism was
what's called a snapshot.
And that's a downloadable
extraction of data,
a custom data set, for whatever
is the specific use case that
can be either transferred
to a cloud provider
to work an existing workflows.
Or it can be downloaded to
any enterprise customers
on-premise behind a firewall.
So if privacy is an issue,
we're able to meet that need.
The second delivery
mechanism we enabled
was what's called a stream.
And that's a custom
filter of incoming news,
near real-time ingestion,
that can either be used
to keep a Datastore up to date.
Or it can be used for
things like risk target
identification, brand
management at scale,
due diligence at scale.
So these are the
delivery mechanisms
we wanted to investigate and
make available via the DNA
platform.
What we discovered early on
in our initial experimentation
with cloud architecture is
that the usage pattern--
moving to the cloud gives
us better opportunity
to track and identify and
understand our usage patterns.
And our architecture
needs to be adjusted
to meet the needs of
our usage patterns.
And we identified
trade-off decisions
that were either
to optimize cost
or to optimize the
performance for our customer.
One opportunity-- so what
we're going to do today
is we're going to use this
balance as an analogy for what
is either the optimization of
cost that's enabled via cloud
services or the
opportunity to improve
your performance
to your customers
by leveraging cloud services.
Cost optimizations-- if we were
going to improve our cost--
for example, in the
use case of a snapshot,
which is a downloadable
extraction,
what we identified as the usage
pattern is very consistent.
So these are workloads that can
be done in batch processing.
These are workloads that
can withstand interruption.
So what we have
is, we could make
an investment in
cost optimization
by using preemptable instances.
We could invest in
cost optimization
by investing in tiered
storage, by leveraging
the advantages of tier storage.
You could do this the same
with sustained use discounts.
And you'll notice, as we
leverage the cost optimization,
the performance may degradate.
So as you're optimizing,
either for cost or performance,
the key is not necessarily
finding equilibrium.
It's striking the
right balance of cost
to performance for
that specific use case.
Now, streams, on the
other hand, which
is a near real-time
filter of data, well,
that we would really
heavily weight being highly
available on being reliable.
In that event, we'd really want
to invest in managed services.
And we'd want to invest
in read/write access.
And we'd also want to invest
in analytics capabilities.
So in investing in
our performance,
the performance time goes
down, but the costs may go up.
So it's really, as
I mentioned, never
a matter of trying to
strike equilibrium.
It's a matter of trying
to find the balance that
meets your specific use case.
So Dylan, once the data was
made available on the cloud,
can you walk us through some
of the cost to performance
trade-offs that you
discovered with Datastore?
DYLAN ROY: Yeah.
So with Datastore, we were
giving high availability
of reads and writes.
And also, it integrates really
well with our pipelining tool,
Dataflow.
It also allows us to scale a
lot better than we did on-prem.
Some of the cons were, it's
very expensive for the read
and write operations,
especially for the usage
patterns we were seeing.
On top of that, we had
to create our own DSL
and educate our
customers on that DSL.
So there was a better way
for us to move forward.
And Patricia?
PATRICIA WALSH: Yeah.
So for the product
of snapshots, we
do require analytics
capabilities,
but we also require the
read/write capabilities.
Datastore proved to really
meet the need for analytics
for the performance
expectation of our customers,
but did not meet the
cost-performant needs.
So Dylan, what were
some of the advantages
of moving towards BigQuery
as our search index?
DYLAN ROY: Yeah.
So I'll explain the
architecture and then
bring to light the
optimizations we
made that made this a better
architecture than the one
that we had for Datastore.
And I'm going to explain it
from right to left starting
with the Mario
pipeline of content.
And so, yeah, that's
still feeding in into GCS
with those events that we're
using to update our archive.
And then we still have
that Dataflow pipeline
that updates daily,
except the difference here
is we separated our query
layer from our storage layer.
And for our query
layer, we use BigQuery.
And BigQuery allows
us to have that SQL--
the standard SQL syntax that we
can use and allow our customers
to leverage as well.
And also, we have GCS to
store our full set of content.
Another reason we had
to split our query layer
and our storage layer
was because there
were some limitations
with BigQuery,
specifically, the extraction
limits that we ran into.
We do not run into this with
the current architecture.
And I'll kind of bring that to
light through the customer's
journey when they submit
a request for a snapshot.
And that can be seen
here on the right side.
Our customers interact
with the APIs.
And what they're requesting
is a snapshot of data.
And once they submit
that request--
an example request would
be for all English content
that we have in our archive.
And that will kick
off a Dataflow job.
And what that
Dataflow job will do
is, it'll go to BigQuery
with that WHERE clause
and grab all the
IDs of the articles
and the identifiers for
the most current version
of each article.
And from that point,
it'll do a co-group key
or just sort of join with the
data we have stored on GCS.
From that point, once it has
all the content identified,
it will then output the
snapshot to a location
that the customer can
use to download it.
But that's still
done via our APIs.
And our customer
still has no idea
that we're no longer
using Datastore.
So that's the architecture.
And I'll kind of reiterate
the pros and cons of this.
So with these
resources that we're
spinning up with Dataflow,
they're ephemeral.
So we're not incurring
that cost as time goes on.
We're only incurring
the cost while we're
doing the operation, we're
doing the snapshot, for example.
We're not paying a high price
for updates to the archive
as we were before
with Datastore.
Also, we get that
free query syntax
that BigQuery gives us with SQL.
And GCS is very cheap.
So it's the perfect
place to store our data
when we're not using it.
So with this
architecture, we still
have that very expensive
joining process
with the query layer
and the storage layer.
And we also need
a separate cluster
for each and every operation.
So there may be a better way.
And you may see that
further on in our talk here.
PATRICIA WALSH: So in
moving to using BigQuery
for our analytics, we were
able to do big workflows
at a relatively inexpensive--
BigQuery's relatively
inexpensive
for analytics capabilities.
But we hit some
quotas and we hit
some limits when it
came to extraction,
which is why we then paired
with Google Cloud Storage.
We really used the
cost optimizations
of the tiered storage with
the analytics capabilities
of BigQuery.
So Dylan, in our
snapshots architecture,
why was the move made
from Dataflow to Dataproc?
DYLAN ROY: OK, yeah.
I'll explain this
architecture, and you
may see the cons
kind of bubble up,
or what no longer are cons
with this architecture.
So here, we still have that
Mario pipeline of content
going into GCS, updating daily,
and going into the content
archive we have here.
That's a little
different, as you may see.
The customer is still
submitting API requests.
But when the customer
submits an API request
for all English
content this time,
they're just going to
be having a job spin up.
And we can use Dataproc
and their SQL syntax
to create this snapshot
of content that'll
be delivered to our customer.
There were some cons
with this method.
But I'll go over those
after I go over the pros,
because this is a good thing.
So with this architecture, we
were able to share resources.
So when we had two customers
make a snapshot request,
we can still use that
same archive of content.
With Dataflow, we'd have to
load into our cluster each
and every time.
Here, we can mount the same
drive and the same content.
So this also more closely
aligns with our usage patterns.
We have more and more customers
join and use our platform.
And because of that, we can
use these higher-cost resources
when it comes to
doing the operations.
There's also no need
for that joining
of the query layer
and the storage layer,
because we're using Spark
on Dataproc which has a SQL
syntax that we can leverage.
But with this, there is still
more operational overhead.
With Dataflow, it can recover
from errors or any issue
with the cluster.
With Dataproc, we still
have to build in some logic
to kind of restart the cluster
and recover from errors.
On top of that, when
we moved from BigQuery
and went to the
Spark syntax, we had
to create some UDFs to bridge
that gap between functionality.
And for those of
you interested, it
was related to
regular expressions.
And I'll throw it
over to Patricia
to continue us on this journey.
PATRICIA WALSH: So we have
a relatively small team.
We started with two engineers,
and we now have five engineers.
Through the experimentation,
in moving to the cloud,
we were able to identify that
the usage pattern for snapshots
is very consistent and
it's very predictable.
So it was a worthwhile
trade-off to go to the increased
overhead of an unmanaged
service as it gave us
increasing control over
the expensive operations
like joining and windowing.
So there was a cost benefit
to us that was worth it
and worth taking
on the overhead.
So Dylan, for streams, which
is a near real-time filtered
stream of data where highly
available services is weighted
heavier, why was the
choice made to move
from Dataflow to Dataproc,
or Dataproc to Dataflow?
DYLAN ROY: Yeah.
We're going backwards
[INAUDIBLE]..
PATRICIA WALSH: We've had that
same conversation 1,000 times.
DYLAN ROY: OK, yeah.
With the streams
architecture, our customers
are going to notice
if it goes down
for a few minutes or seconds,
unlike with snapshots.
They're not going to notice
because those operations are
going to take between
an hour or two hours.
This, it's low
latency, so they're
going to notice when messages
are not streaming to them.
With this, we're still hooking
into that stream of content
that's coming from
the Mario tube.
But it's streaming on
to pub/sub right now.
And we're still leveraging
the Dataflow services
to do our ETL processes.
And the great thing
about Dataflow
is you can write job for
a batch or streaming job,
and it's going to be
either the same or similar.
So we're taking
advantage of some
of the code we
wrote for snapshots
and using it in streams
to filter in and update
our content.
From that point, we filter it
into different product types
because we have
content that's licensed
to only certain products.
And we use Dataflow to
filter that content.
From there, this is
where our customers
interact with our system.
They use our user APIs as if
they would be using a snapshot.
They submit the same query.
Like, if they want
all English content,
they'll submit that
little WHERE clause.
And from that point, we'll
spin up a Dataflow filter.
Before, though, that
was a Dataproc filter.
And I'll go into the pros
and cons as to why we changed
that part of the architecture.
So once the customer
has created the stream
and they have their custom
set of content streaming
to them on this
pub/sub topic here,
they can then use
our client code
and get streamed
all the content that
gets filtered down to them.
But we had to make that move
that I was talking earlier,
from Dataproc to Dataflow.
And that was because, every
time we would use preemptables
in our cluster, it would
take down our stream,
and our customers would notice.
With Dataflow, we
actually have had
streams that have been
running for multiple years.
Along with that, it allows for
this fully-managed zero-ops
data processing.
And for our small
team, this is great
because we don't have to wake
up in the middle of the night
and handle an issue.
It also allows for more
seamless auto-scaling,
which helps with smaller teams.
And with streams, there was
not heavy load, as we only
receive 800,000 messages a day.
In big data land,
that's not a lot.
So yeah.
There were the cons of not
being able to use preemptables,
which were very cheap.
If you do use Dataproc, I
suggest looking into it.
And also, we had to leverage
an in-memory database
for the queries.
We didn't have the BigQuery
syntax or the Spark syntax
that we could plug
into and use SQL.
But if I were to do
this again, Dataflow now
has a SQL DSL, which
we have not used.
I'll throw it over
to you, Patricia.
PATRICIA WALSH: Thanks.
So sort of to summarize some
of the lessons learned--
the usage patterns seem obvious.
But actually, once we
released it to the world,
we did have some
APIs that were used
in ways we hadn't intended.
And all of a sudden,
your costs skyrocket,
and you start becoming
very painfully
aware of where you have
opportunity to optimize
and where you have
opportunity to change.
And so what I would
recommend and advise is,
initially, we were
always optimizing
for performant responses.
And if you invest too heavily
in one side of the trade-offs,
you fall over on
top of yourself.
If you're only
investing in one side,
you get skewed off
balance really quickly.
And that becomes very
apparent when you
get the bill for the service.
We had a use case that ended up
being, like, a $70,000 use case
that we were not expecting.
So what we really
learned is-- and anytime
we do a feature development--
to first identify the usage
pattern, identify the
behavior, really understand,
from your users, how
they're intending to use it,
which might be different than
your original assumption.
And then once you do
understand the usage pattern,
to build in such a flexible
way that you can understand
the trade-off
decisions you've made
versus the performant
experience for your customer
and your opportunities
that the cloud enables you
for costs optimizations.
So Dylan, what were
some of the lessons
you learned in making this new
product available on Google
Cloud?
DYLAN ROY: Yeah.
One thing that we found
useful as we were developing
this new product that we've
not built before was we
built time in our roadmap
to iterate and spike
our new infrastructure
when we could.
Google's always developing new
zero-ops tools that you can use
and other cloud
providers are as well.
We actually started on a
different cloud provider
before we moved to Google.
Also, we learned that
being an early adopter
is a double-edged sword.
You can guide the roadmap
for their products.
But, at the same time, you
can use one of their products,
and it can tip over in a
way you would not previously
have expected.
Also, Google very tightly--
they keep their quotas down
to a limit that prevent you
from incurring a lot of
costs, but at the same time,
it could cause an
issue in the future.
So it's good to know
your quotas especially
when you're an early adopter.
So yeah.
This can actually be boiled
down to three things when you're
deciding on your architecture.
The first one is cost.
The larger you can make that
margin for costs of operations,
the quicker you can grow your
team and iterate on features.
Another one is team size.
There are some
architectures that
may not work for
your small teams,
especially if you want to have a
team that can develop features.
And you don't want to be
spending half of that time
managing infrastructure.
This is why Google
Dataflow and Dataproc
have actually come in handy for
us and accelerated our roadmap.
Another one we kind of
learned trial by fire
is usage patterns.
We had a new product
with a new use case.
And our customers were
using it in a way we did not
expect them to use it.
As a result, we took
advantage of the fact
that we had time in our
roadmap from using these zero
operational tools
and also the fact
that we built into a roadmap
this time for iterating
on our architecture.
So luckily, we were able to
adapt and change according
to these usage patterns.
But it's very important to
keep a very tight eye on that
and maybe even log
that data somewhere
so you can be alerted of when
your costs are kind of spiking,
and it's time to
address that issue.
So those are the
lessons I learned.
PATRICIA WALSH: Yeah.
So in making this new product
available on the cloud,
our existing use cases
of advanced research,
we've also now made a
new line of business
for machine learning
and big data workflows.
And Dylan's going to walk us
through some of what we've also
enabled in terms of applying
these lessons to even
future-proofing in some kind
of new and upcoming things
we've got going on.
DYLAN ROY: Yeah.
So this was just
about news content.
But with news content, you
have different entities.
You have organizations, you
have people, you have events,
you have different industries
affecting the news.
So there's a lot of
context that can be gleaned
from different sets of data.
And DNA has allowed us to build
on the top of the shoulders
of this platform
and create products
that can generate knowledge.
And actually, you can get a
signal from these news events.
And we're doing that by
structuring a Knowledge
Graph, in the way that Google is
doing for their search engine,
we're going to be doing
for the news and events.
So we've been able to work
on that, develop new context,
traverse relations through
our graph architecture.
And on top of that, if
you're interested in the kind
of content we've been
dealing with here,
we have a commercial
data set in BigQuery.
Just Google BigQuery
commercial data sets DNA,
and you can take a look
at the news content
we've been dealing with.
So yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
PATRICIA WALSH: Yeah.
So the Knowledge Graph
is the next big thing
we've got coming up.
And we're so excited to have
this premium news content,
but also available with
the entities that exist,
the relationships
between those entities,
so you have the
data in the context
of the data, which is something
we're really excited about.
[MUSIC PLAYING]